[Music]
kyle is with us in
santa rosa california hey kyle how are
you
mr ramsey it's an honor to talk to you
sir you too sir what's up
uh okay so quick question i'm a i am a
big listener a friend of mine who's also
a listener
uh recommended something to me i wanted
to run it by you
um i have a pickup truck that is the
2006
uh duramax diesel he is
suggesting with the high market value of
used cars right now to sell it to put it
towards
and potentially pay off my debt
what's the truck worth uh blue book
value is it hazard at about 14.
how much debt do you have 20 grand
how old are you i'm 34
or i'll be 34 next week what do you make
uh with my with my wife and i we we
grossed about 145 last year
is this your daily driver truck or is it
a third vehicle or
extra vehicle uh well my wife has a car
with our family car with a new baby that
we just had
and then i have my truck okay so i would
i would end up selling it to
get get a hooky as you like to call it
yeah
uh to be my driver yeah do you like the
truck
i do like the truck um you know
and that's what my buddy was saying is
that he was saying to
you know get rid of the truck it's just
a truck
put it towards your debt work towards
your house well if it was 40 if it was
44
000 maybe but it's only a 14 000 truck
it's not
it doesn't fix the problem and it's not
that big a percentage of 145 000. if you
like it i would keep it and
get your get your butt on a budget and
get this 20 grand in debt paid off and
keep your truck
it's just a faster way for you to jump
start your debt
paying off but you can on that income
you can do this without selling it
i would not sell it instead i would roll
up my sleeves and get my household on a
tight budget everybody in the house and
let's get this twenty thousand dollars
paid
off i don't know you make 145 let's
uh let's do it in five months
okay four thousand dollars four thousand
dollars a month you can do that on that
income
and you get to keep your truck it's a
little
it's a little bit slower than you doing
it next week yeah i mean if you sell the
truck you're still going to be
you still got six thousand dollars in
that's still going to take you two more
months yeah
yeah so the difference is a hooptie for
for saving you three months
it's not and then you know i wouldn't do
anything to move back up out of hoopty
into a better car
yeah right and and so
that was just the only reason i was
thinking about it because of the like i
said the
uh the demand for used vehicles today
yeah but so what i mean again if it was
a 54 000 truck i'd sell it in a
heartbeat on you
sure but it's just it's not it's not
that big a percentage
of the problem or of your income
so it doesn't move the needle enough for
the hassle
is my point got it got it if you hate
the truck anyway
then yeah let's dump it while the
market's high and get you something else
but
that's not the problem you don't owe 14
on it right
no i don't weigh anything on it yeah
your only debt is 20 000
other than your home uh yeah i don't we
don't own our home so we don't even have
that okay all right hey uh hold on i'm
gonna have kelly sign you guys up
for a year in ramsey plus and put you
into financial peace university
and get you on to every dollar premium
budgeting app
and so we're going to show you how to
budget and how to handle your money
and how to work your way through this
debt and you're going to be able to see
after you go through financial peace
university with your wife
uh you guys are going to be able to see
if you'll dial into this i'll give it to
you for you for a year if you'll dial
into it
but you got to go do it and then you got
to call me back and tell me you're debt
free
but um you're going to be able to see
what christy and i are seeing because
we've looked at this
for years decades and so we can see
instantly that
yeah you need to just pay off this debt
but if you're gonna screw around and
take four years to get out of debt or
something with twenty thousand dollars
then
you got other problems that are not
truck that the truck doesn't solve
yeah and especially on that income like
this is very doable on that income if
you're calling in with the 30 000
income that's different but you can do
this